hélène buzzetti chantal hébert alec
castonguay bonsoir
alors ces images de calme je pense qu'on
va la remettre ça fait nous fait du bien
après une fin de semaine agitée la
semaine dernière après la description du
tout ces images nous collègues je l' ai
dit d'entrée de jeu à l'émission rg
saluer nos collègues qui ont été de
radio-canada du tva de tout le monde ctv
cbc qui ont été sur le terrain très
froid en plus et ça brassait alors bon
tout est calme alors tout étant calme
est-ce qu'on a encore besoin de cette
loi taux de table après ce jeu vous
faire entendre des extraits mais d'abord
tour de table 1
mais écoutez on se retrouve dans une
situation bancale parce que le vote sur
cette loi a eu lieu ce soir donc
exactement une semaine après son
invocation mai et donc les députés le
voient comme un vote pour pérenniser
entre prolonger l'application de la loi
alors qu'en fait il faut quand même le
voir comme navale qu'on donne ou compte
d'impôts au fait d'avoir utilisé la loi
et c'est ce qui explique le fait que le
gouvernement déclare que c'est un vote
de confiance du bout des lèvres mais
quand même parce que si ce vote devait
pas passer ça créerait une situation
assez particulière
le gouvernement n'aurait pas eu la
confiance d'avoir fait ce qui le déjà
fait alors je pense qu'on s'est vite
d'un gros mélodrame parlementaires à
faire passer ce soir ce qui ne veut pas
dire que on peut pas arrêter la loi dans
deux trois ou cinq jours c'est très
intéressant ce que ce que vous dites
cette nuance et que c'est un vote sur le
passé presque de la dernière semaine
parce que monsieur labati viens de le
dire la loi d'ici la fin de la semaine
oui c'est possible qu'on retire ce qu'on
n'aura plus besoin chantal
totalement d'accord avec hélène
ce vote
est fait pour valider ce que le
gouvernement a décidé de faire
c'est-à-dire invoqué la loi mais d'autre
part il sert à protéger aussi le
gouvernement du canada contre des
contestations juridiques qui va y en
avoir sur sa décision d'avoir eu recours
à la loi sur les mesures d'urgence alors
imaginer que le gouvernement pendant une
semaine fait ce que fait et qui
n'obtient pas l'aval du parlement la
chambre des communes s'est affaiblie
nettement sa cause en cour
l'idée est qu'on dise du bout des lèvres
que c'est un vote de confiance je pense
que c'est incontournable que ce soit un
vote de confiance si la chambre des
communes n'a pas confiance une majorité
enregistré trudeau sur l'utilisation
d'une loi de ce genre là et c'est
difficile de dire qui a encore de la
confiance à l'égard des minoritaires et
monsieur la médecine je les ai sa
candeur mais je pense que candide audi
c'est pour les libéraux et c'est pour
les libéraux pas ça peut-être à monsieur
ne s'est pas passé qui est ce que les
libéraux alec aller voter contre mais ça
c'est une parenthèse mais sur l'ensemble
de l'oeuvre également alizée gaillard
ait pu y avoir un ou deux députés
libéraux aux plus sceptiques se demander
effectivement s'il devait voter avec le
gouvernement mais je pense pas que
massivement les députés libéraux ont
rapporté deux côtés du gouvernement
cette loi leur les corps policiers l'ont
dit je pense qu'elle aurait été utile la
semaine dernière donner de nouveaux
pouvoirs aux corps policiers le
certainement aidé est reçue a dit la
poursuite de certains barrages celui de
kout celui des machines
dernière donc on l'enterrait aujourd'hui
me semble dans l'ordre des choses est-ce
que là par contre on devrait la mettre
des 30 jours parce que c'est là
puisqu'ils prévu ça ça me semble
beaucoup ont fait paraître c'est
préventif avoir ce type de de loi là en
place et touche pas à ce bien peut-être
qu'on pourrait raccourcir le délai david
un métier le plus évoqué votre balle
hors de portée de vue patrice ça peut
être quelques jours au sein
d'une église
sur l'île sous texte à la fin de la
semaine lui elle va dire fois ci à rien
nouveau carré bien sûr on va télégraphié
un peu plus clairement aujourd'hui me
semble-t-il que ça aurait été utile dans
le débat mais parce qu'on va maintenir
de manière prolongée mais pour ce qui
est d'entraîner la dernière semaine ça
me semble évident que lebron les avaries
sans parler des bords on va entendre des
extraits monsieur trudon de monsieur
singh qui va voter pour et de monsieur
blanchet qui ont voté contre est-ce
qu'on a conservateurs dont je crois pas
mais ils vont voter contre bien sûr une
écoute
mais on sent encore que ces jours ci
dans le moment présent
la situation est encore fragile
la situation d'urgence est encore
présente
nous allons continuer de surveiller au
jour le jour pour voir quand est-ce
qu'on pourra le lever ce sera pas pour
l'immédiat mais à tous les jours on va
réévaluer puis on n'espère pas le garder
une journée de plus que nécessaire
notre appui pour sept votes et avec
réticence et on va continuer de dire ce
que j'ai dit j'ai avisé le gouvernement
j'ai avisé les prêts ministre que notre
appui
ne va pas continuer pour le long durée
de 30 jours que on est prêt à relever
notre appui si jamais le cac est on est
on ne pense pas qu'ils aient si
nécessaire de continuer d'appuyer
avec le premier ministre ajoute une
contrainte à une contrainte il évoque la
loi la plus contre un gang de l'arsenal
juridique et parce qu'il a peur de se
planter ils menacent d'imposer la
contraignent d'en faire un vote de
confiance c'est un constat d'échec et
c'est certainement peintre de courage
hélène jouets et chantal et alec je vous
montre un tableau il ya eu 200 6 210
quand 219 faisant remonter ses comptes
bancaires gelés ça c'est beaucoup la loi
les véhicules remorqués il aurait pu
mais ça a été plus facile avec la loi
puis le les arrestations accusations ça
ça un peu rien à boire mais c'est le
bilan de l'opération néanmoins alec vous
l'avez vous l'avais dit en passant les
policiers ont dit depuis jeudi ça nous
est utile ça fâche faciliter la
coordination hélène un mot sur cette
opération policière qui a été
lancée vendredi matin
vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure dans
votre entrevue avec monsieur lâm et y un
patrice quand vous a dit ses ports à peu
le propre des policiers de toujours
demander plus de moyens plus d'outils et
c'est un bon point c'est très valide
mais en même temps c'est aussi une
réalité en tout cas un constat qu'on
doit poser que à tort ou à raison les
autorités en place estimait ne pas avoir
d' outils suffisants pour intervenir
dans cette occupation alors on peut
quand même pas nier que cette loi ont
été efficaces les gels bancaire en
particulier semble avoir été
un incitatif à 6 puis salle comme tout
d'un coup là vous avez plus d'accès à
votre carte de guichet pour aller
acheter du café thé morton bon vous
réchauffer ça a un effet très certain
par même et un petit mot aussi le maire
watson qui proposait con con revendre
les camions qui ont été saisis le pauvre
payé les frais le gouvernement ne peut
pas dire si ces permis mais bon je pense
qu'ils leur mise est cette idée ils ont
tous été aujourd'hui que les camions
seront gardés à la fourrière sept jours
ensuite deux seuls les gens pourront
lire perry pour savoir que ces camions
l'alleud souvent ils valent dans les six
chiffres
fiscale
sur chantal et alex sur l'opération
policière sur la façon dont s'approcher
dit qu'est ce que vous en dites chantage
ça a procédé comme une opération
policière devrait procéder comme elle a
procédé à québec comme elle a procédé au
pont ambassador et je pense que le
message du gouvernement en écoutant
votre entrevue avec le ministre les
métiers aux forces de police et
organisez vous pour être prêt la
prochaine fois parce qu'on va pas garder
si ces mesures-là en place pendant une
journée de plus que ce qu'on a besoin de
le faire et vous avez jackson 5 qui dit
il est bien entendu on ne sera pas
d'accord pour 30 jours
entendons-nous il suffit que vingt
députés demandent convoite une motion
pour évoquer la loi pour que dans les
trois jours on doive ans débarque dans
une chambre ou l'autre du sénateur ou 20
députés et attentif du moment débat
commence il ya 10 heures pour se
conclure et y envoient alors c'est pas
comme si le gouvernement effectivement
avait
un espèce de bail qui pouvait renouveler
à ballon t on sent que ça pourra pas de
jury est d'ailleurs le npd moi je me dis
doit il rendre certaine nervosité quand
même dans les rangs même si les
partisans néo-démocrate majoritairement
10 aux sondeurs qui sont d'accord oui
mais quand brad benson comme il est
sorti aujourd'hui pour défendre la
position du npd
quand on sort est brass band
généralement ça me rejoint détruits oui
alex sûrs sur la durée je pense que les
jeunes des genres compris le quai ils
n'ont pas le choix même s'il le voulait
ça va être court d'une part mais je
reviens sur l'opération qui a été
chorégraphié avec la société tellement
lent au début on de laisser ces gens
s'installer mais là en fin de semaine ça
a été une opération policière qui roule
iront demain là quand même
ouais j'en ai couvert beaucoup de
manifestations dans un autre temps et
puis
moi je te croise celle ci a town en
direct - les regards de tous regardé pas
mal il y avait beaucoup de nos collègues
qui étaient sur place je me souviens pas
d'une opération d'aussi grande envergure
où il ya eu en réalité assez peu
d'escarmouches louis a eu évidemment les
à droite et à gauche des poches de
résistance où il ya eu des cinq ans à
brasser un peu plus mais en général
qu'on ait procédé à ce type
d'arrestation si au niveau g20 à toronto
serait pas si longtemps mille
arrestations les pendant 6 ou là on n'a
pas fait de souricière on n'a pas essayé
de compter les manifestants les a
laissés sortir comme il voulait tout le
temps qu'ils devaient prendre le talent
y est méthodiquement avec sept corps
policiers différents je travaillais pas
toujours de la même manière on a réussi
à procéder comme ça dans une robe en
relatif calme par rapport à ce que ça
aurait pu être
le noyau le plus radical qui restait
dans la ville honnêtement pour ceux qui
connaissent encore plus sauf que moi je
regardais sur les réseaux sociaux le des
journalistes spécialisés en opérations
policières ont dit ces présidents j'ai
presque en un manuel d'instructions
qu'on devrait à enseigner maintenant
dans les écoles de police sur le
contrôle des foules n'est jamais parfait
mais en général c'est probablement ce
qui pouvait arriver de mieux cette
opération là de la manière dont ça s'est
déroulé ça a été beaucoup souligné par
les gens sur place par nos collègues
effectivement
chorégraphié au quart du tour bon là on
voit beaucoup les chevaux d'ailleurs il
ya eu une fausse information manet qui
sortit l'écart était morte est pas vrai
mais il ya une enquête pour savoir parce
que quelqu'un était blessé alors il y
aura une enquête faite sur cet épisode
là des chevaux ok l'ukraine
monsieur poutine là qui est allé d'un
discours enflammé qui a
sorti toutes ces récriminations face à
au passé à l'urss que laisser tomber
dit-il injustement p'tain erreur
historique les républiques soviétiques
unes après les autres sans dédommagement
et l'ukraine en particulier disponible
un vrai pays d'une colonie américaine
d'un bref
c'était le président d'un petit pays on
dirait bon ben ça va c'est quand même
poutine avec la force qu'il a derrière
lui qu'est ce que le canada lé parce que
là les deux républiques
pro russe une partie qui seront
vraisemblablement annexé en tout cas je
poutine les eaux reconnus indépendants
qu'est ce que le canada peut faire est
ce que ça va changer la politique
perspective là tu tour de table et là
écoutez j'ai aucune idée de comment le
gouvernement canadien
mais espérons que ça sera peut-être
différent d'avec la crimée on a
l'impression avec monsieur poutine que
on a déjà joué dans un même film avec la
clim est justement la géorgie il a
toujours cette même procédure que
j'appelle ça comme une partition
extérieur et y procède à pas halal au
morcellement du territoire qu'il veut
reconquérir
jusqu'à présent à le canada s'était
montré assez discret on sent une
certaine crainte de de se mettre le le
coup sur le bio de d'avoir l'air trop
différent de nous allier donc on en voit
constamment le pod de nos alliés
principalement américains notamment
alors j'imagine que ce sera la même
chose mais clairement d'avoir une telle
hausse de ton il va falloir que le
canada ait l'air à la hauteur de cette
hausse marquée monsieur ben dunn qui a
émis un décret qui indiquerait c'est pas
non plus une réaction il
voit qu'il est plus sain et dont on va
couper tout lien avec ces deux
républiques chantal et alec que faire
devant
un homme comme celui là bon d'abord la
balle est dans le camp de l'union
européenne la france l'allemagne c'est
pas le canada qui est en première ligne
et oui le président américain parce que
c'est un peu l'avenir de l'europe qui se
joue là dedans et pas seulement l'avenir
de l'ukraine mais là venaient aussi la
lettonie 7 alice mais
c'est néanmoins pour le canada qui va
dire à la france et à l'allemagne à la
grande bretagne le mans défend leurs
intérêts en territoire européen on a
déjà vu que le ton du canada avait monté
un peu un on a accepté de vendre ce
qu'on appelle des armes létales métal
alterne mortels donc il ya eu il ya eu
une montée d'un cran mais entendons-nous
de canada à gillois pas unilatéralement
immergé sous les auspices de l'otan un
jour si ça continue la question va se
poser la pire celle que justin trudeau
est propre à savoir est ce qu'on aura
est-ce qu'on contribue des troupes
si une contre offensive militaire avec
d'abord le canada ne joue aucun rôle
important dans cette crise là c'est bien
dommage pour ceux qui auraient aimé que
l'on joué mais on n'est effectivement
pas un joueur important
chantal elano raison l'union européenne
l'allemagne et la france au premier chef
sont vraiment là au coeur de cette jeu
diplomatique là on au seuil entre
soulagement et inquiétude aujourd'hui
dans les capitales occidentales
soulagement un sens où est ce que pour
ne pas perdre la face l'asie mais
poutine dans le fond c'est ce qu'ils
souhaitaient peser roddick 6 et 2 1 tb
kg qui sont déjà pas mal indépendante en
réalité du territoire ukrainien y va
pouvoir dire ben voilà maintenant je
range les armes et tranquillement ont
des escalades et on aura donc eu la
réaction des pays occidentaux outre et
quelques sanctions des décrets et on en
reste là où est ce que c'est le prélude
à quelque chose de plus agressif marché
sur kiev l'invasion de l'ukraine ce
qu'on craignait depuis des semaines avec
le dans le fond ce soit la première
étape de quelque chose de plus grand et
ce en réalité on ne le sait pas et à peu
près personne qu'il s'est même à
l'entourage de vladimir poutine je suis
pas certain qu'on sait où il veut en
arriver à véritablement avec 7 cette
pression là qu'il exerce sur l'inné
occidentaux depuis des semaines donc les
prochaines heures vont être critiques le
reste on a ce qu'on arrête là et on s'en
tient ce statu quo et place mais petit
mot pour dire vous voyez j'ai fait
quelque chose pour nos amis pro russe en
ukraine où est ce que dans le fond il va
se dit pas la réaction est assez timoré
je pousse plus loin et on va avoir des
journées assez intense le
oui c'est bien résumé c est ce que c'est
la porte de sortie pour poutine face à
ces heureux sous six ans d'envoyé on a
agi ou c'est pas la porte d'entrée plus
là ça va dépendre aussi hélène et
chantal les réactions de l'ukraine est
ce qu'il y aura des combats de l'ukraine
va dire très bien détaché vous ces deux
ont là où il y aura pas de vrai combat
xi avait de vrais combats mais c'est une
invitation à poutine d'entrée au 6 mai
mais l'analyse dada league est très
bonne est-ce que ça s'arrête là où plus
tard mais ça n'est pas comment on voit
le plus tard on avait un peu dit la même
chose avec la crimée bombay sa saveur et
déloge bon on peut circonscrire le
problème
on a l'impression que monsieur poutine a
une vision à très très très long terme
et que sont plus tard pour lui peut être
pas toutes les années plus tard mais
quelle comme ça ils avancent toujours un
peu plus alors cette considération la
garde à l'esprit j'ai entendu cela dit
personne est éternel j'ai inclus platini
à poutine de ne pas se suivre à
paris et dans la liste des moyens
l'annoncé
qui va envoyer des troupes de maintien
de la paix dans ces deux provinces là
je suis pas convaincu que l'ukraine peut
tolérer ou même la communauté
internationale plus considérés comme
autre chose que de commencer à s'emparer
d'une partie du territoire de voilà on
va suivre ça tamara ans on va lui
reparle au téléjournal 1 18 heures elle
est à la frontière merci beaucoup à vous
trois bonbonnes semaine au revoir aux
réservoirs pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez vous sur la chaîne ici et
redit